i'm not even getting clean and sober
that we fixed a lot of our problems
[Music]
i know
in that clip mr deputy tell mr i'm never
getting clean and sober correct
it sounds like
to me
that uh yes either that or i have never
been clean and sober thank you let's
play 2304 please
in the big picture the big schemer
thinks it does nothing but hurt us and
why because of cold blues doesn't make
it easier for you to see how clearly
that is
you got to stop with the coconut oil all
the coke all the coke you've done today
and all the booze you've drank today by
the way has it helped you
has it helped us just got the coke has
it helped us it's fun yeah i know
because la yesterday you are a thousand
times better
yesterday
i'd like to turn now to a few more of
your words around the time that you went
into detox about how you viewed amber's
role in that process mr deb is the
second text from the bottom a text that
you sent to amber's mom page
on august 19 2014
yes that's correct and this is when you
were
either in the middle of or finishing up
your detox process from roxy codon
correct that is correct and in this text
message that you write amber's mom on
august 19 2014 you say my dearest page
how unbelievably kind and pure your
message was i am beyond thankful to have
you in my life there is no luckier man
on this earth
to have the strength that amber gives me
and the full support of each of you
individually
that i've gotten
helps immeasurably
i don't need to explain the horrors to
you
you know as well as i
what you do need to know
that your daughter has risen far above
the nightmarish task of taking care of
this poor old junkie
never a second has gone by that she
didn't look out for me or have her eyes
on me to make sure that i was okay
y and words are truly feeble in
attempting to explain her heroism in a
text
suffice to say that i have never met or
loved a woman or a thing more
she has the strength of a thousand men
and that is due
to no one or nothing but you sweetheart
thank you i love you
your son outlaw
did i read that correctly
you did
you